hard drives are much cheaper than SSDs
unfortunately they're also much slower
and says that it's obtain memory can
dramatically boost the speed of hard
drives to SSD like levels but does it
actually work can it actually boot up
your games faster let's find out
[Music]
interrupts a memory is based on a new
non-volatile memory Express technology
called 3d crosspoint Intel asserts that
it is up to 1,000 times faster than NAND
flash at the architectural level it uses
a PCIe drive based on the m-dot to form
factor used in conjunction with an HDD
boot drive Insull says that it's opting
memory can act as it's super fast
catching dive that can dramatically
accelerate the load times of your most
used games in application and spoiler
warning for the most part it works we'll
get to the benchmarks in a bit while
caching drives are nothing new as we've
had hard drives with small amounts of
NAND flash those onto them for years in
the form of solid-state hybrid drives
man simply isn't fast enough to lift
slow spinning drives out of a
performance slump using one of these SS
HDS is like driving on a one line
highway with the occasional passing lane
the passing lane ie the NAND in the
scenario is definitely helpful but at
the end of the day you're still driving
on a one lane highway with 3d crosspoint
being so much faster that one occasional
passing lane now opens up to what
amounts to Germany's crazy fast Autobahn
freeway system one major roadblocks
using opti memory is that you will need
a seventh generation KB Lake CPU coupled
with a 200 series motherboard that has
an MDOT to swap the company tells me
that it takes approximately four runs
before octane can properly cache
applications to reach optimal efficiency
as a result I ran all octane tests four
times I plotted these results from left
to right in sequential order and
compared them to my standalone hard
drive run in the following chart my
first benchmarks is a simple Windows 10
boot disk using a stopwatch I timed how
long it took the PC the load of Windows
10 and vowed Steam client from a cold
boot a hard drive took a little over 35
seconds when you take the average of my
four octane runs you end up with a 29
buuut time well that's not as fast as an
SSD that is a 21% advantage over the
standalone hard drive Intel search that
games can launch up to 67 percent faster
with Intel obtain memory so I ran
fallout 4 for my game boots out the hard
drive booted up to the main menu and 7.5
seconds obtains first one launched the
game in 4.2 seconds and got slightly
faster with each iteration when loading
a save file in fallout 4 the hard drive
took 41 seconds before I could actually
jump into the game's post-apocalyptic
world the average of my four obscene
ones came after 33 seconds which is 22%
faster than the hard drive by itself I
also tested in toast claim that octane
can launch Google Chrome up to 5 times
faster than a traditional hard drive the
HDD by itself launched Google sprouted
in roughly 2,400 milliseconds whereas
the hard drive coupled with octane took
less than 300 milliseconds on average
that's over 8 times as fast as the hard
drive by upon these millisecond
advantages may not sound like much but
they can add up over time instances the
octane will allow you to search and find
files up to four times faster compared
to a hard drive so I conducted a
stopwatch test doing a file search for
Windows Media Player it took over 50
seconds for the hard drugs both all
relevant results obtained was noticeably
faster with the first one clocking in at
around 20 seconds oddly enough each
subsequent update search took a little
longer than the last for now Intel's
releasing its obtained memory in two
sizes the company asserts that it's $44
16 gigabyte model offers enough cash for
most mainstream users Intel says that
its $77 32 gigabyte stick which I tested
is better for power users who use a wide
variety of applications if you're
constantly juggling a bunch of different
programs and games you may reach a
caching bottleneck even the Autobahn can
get congested every now and then
this means the traditional SATA based
SSDs aren't going away anytime soon
although opt a memory doesn't always
live up to infill fluffy claims it
sometimes exceeds them it's no
replacement for an SSD in the event that
you reach a caching bottleneck but it is
dramatically faster than a hard drive if
you're adverse to buying an SSD for
whatever reason then we highly recommend
Intel
obtain memories but what do you think do
you think this can replace SSDs let us
know in the comments below if you liked
this video hit the like button and
subscribe to us on YouTube thank you for
watching